aujourd'hui on va se projeter un petit
peu dans le futur on va partir au 26
décembre et au 22 janvier pour parler du
honor view 20 alors je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez en début d'année on aura
présenté son honneur view disent qu'ils
ont rô le smartphone le plus haut de
gamme de la marque celui qui a les
dernières techno des arrières innovation
un instant t le nord juli c'était déjà
un excellent smartphone et il est encore
aujourd'hui dont le design un petit peu
souffert parce qu'il est un petit peu
passer d'un autre côté il ya un an donc
c'est normal on en a présenté le 26
décembre en chine sont au nord view
vainquit et successeur du haut-anjou 10
et qui a toutes les dernières
technologies est pas tout
en tout cas les plus innovantes un
smartphone qu'on ira voir nous
directement lors de la présentation à
paris de présentation mondiale pour le
reste du monde
le 22 janvier prochain donc je vous
invite à vous abonner dès maintenant
pour suivre tout ça parce qu'on y sera
et on le verra en direct et ce au nord
view 20 fait vraiment plein de belles
promesses et nous montre en tout cas là
où on va aller en 2019
en termes de smartphones en termes de
design en termes de puissance de
performance vous allez voir c'est
complètement bluffant
[Musique]
alors vous savez si vous êtes abonnés si
vous suivez même si vous n'êtes pas
donné que vous suivez très régulièrement
d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas abonné je
vous invite à vous abonner
on parle beaucoup de nouvelles techno
beaucoup de smartphones parce que c'est
vraiment l'objet technologique tout le
monde a avec soin et ça nous permet
vraiment de percevoir un peu là où on va
aller les usages vraiment des choses qui
sont hyper hyper hyper intéressante au
nord c'est une marque hyper intéressante
à six parce que c'est la marque un peu
plus jeunes de huawei un peu moins cher
que huawei mais avec des techno hyper
bonne et qui se développe énormément qui
très intéressante à suivre
on a eu plein de modèles cool en 2018 au
nord view 10 au nord 10 ans par plein de
produits hyper cool dans la gamme on
parle de produits qui sont d'entrée de
gamme jetaient les produits haut de
gamme mais à des tarifs sont toujours
hyper hyper compétitif et avec le honor
view 20 au nord va continuer et nous
montre un truc est super cool c'est
l'innovation de l'écran c'est une vraie
innovation c'est un vrai designer
travaille au niveau de l'écran parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on voit on voit que l'on
coche quelque chose qui est extrêmement
critique et qui était pas du tout
l'unanimité à certains qu'ils aiment
mais il y en a qui détestent
pertinemment il ya des marques qui se
refuse à y aller notamment comme samsung
et puis des marques qui ont des modèles
qu'ils ont d'autres modèles qui l'ont
pas ski notamment le cas de aux normes
avec leurs nouveaux modèles
le honor view 20 qui va être présenté
fin d'année en chine l'encoche ne sera
plus là néanmoins on va aller sur très
grand écran avec juste un petit rond
pour laisser passer la caméra un
diamètre de 4,5 mm autant vous dire que
c'est pas très très gros situera en haut
à gauche du smartphone alors c'est assez
intéressant parce que ça montre quoi ça
montre que le ratio écran smartphones va
continuer de s'agrandir on était déjà
les 93 % on peut monter un petit peu
plus haut par 95% ce qui serait
franchement énorme
ça montre que le multimédia continue à
prendre de l'ampleur c'est à dire des
plus grands écrans multimédias pour plus
d'immersion pour regarder notamment de
youtube comme vous le faites tout de
suite ça peut être d'une aide fixée
peut-être pas mal de choses ça peut être
des jeux donc vraiment un univers
multimédia
autre point qui est vraiment hyper hyper
intéressant d'avoir le dernier kirin 982
silicone c'est le stock qu'on peut
retrouver dans le may 20 pro
dans le mythe 20 c'est leur dernier
succès le plus haut de gamme chez eux
qui est très performant en terme
d'autonomie deçà bien évidemment ça
dépend toujours des usages qui va être
toujours plus performants que pour la
rapidité
lorsque vous allez jouer lorsque
délivrer des applications est fermé et
qui va être encore meilleurs pour venir
vous des tours et notamment pour le mode
portrait pour améliorer la photo pour
rajouter des effets là dessus on s'est
pas trop je pense qu'on aura enfin au
moins du cij igad ram 4 gigas de ram
c'est un grand grand grand minimum
j'aimerais bien une version 6 giga de
ram et une version 8 gigas de ram bon ça
on verra un petit peu ce qui se
profilera au niveau de la batterie je
serais surpris qu'on n'ait pas une
batterie au moins de 4000 millions
pérore peut-être même 4800 millions
terreur allez savoir
et puis là où ça va vraiment hausser au
niveau de la photo parce qu'on a un
capteur sony alors attendez la référence
et sony ericsson 586 qu'il y aura un
capteur arrière de 48 mégapixels alors
qu'est ce qu'on va faire à 48 millions
pixels
l'idée c'est pas d'avoir du pixel pour
avoir du pixel mais est ce que ça peut
être pour nous sortir c'est lorsque vous
arrivez sur des conditions de faible
luminosité on va combiner de plusieurs
pixels pour faire une espèce de super
grand pixels qui vous fera plus de
lumière qui en gros pour nous sortir une
image un équivalent 12 mégapixels
lumineux avec une super bonne qualité à
l'avant de retrouver une caméra de 25
méga pixels bon la caméra de ses fils
toujours l'état nérac un petit peu en
deçà la plus grosse caméra reste
notamment à l'arrière au niveau de la
fac de luminosité on ralentit à la
techno qui s'appelle light fusionnent
est un peu ce qu'on trouve aujourd'hui
dans tous les smartphones qui vont faire
des photos de nuit c'est à dire qu
allez-vous faire des photos à
différentes expositions exposition très
faible exposition standard exposition
très haute on assemble tout ça et ça
nous permet d'avoir une photo sur
lesquels tous les détails vont pouvoir
ressortir un ciel qui va pas être cramé
une façade comme on va bien percevoir ça
donc ça fonctionne très bien sur des
photos aumône conditions de luminosité
sa optimiste des images mais également
en photo nuit donc ça c'est vraiment un
truc qui est hyper cool et on voit que
ça les techno qui vont devenir en tout
cas où qu'ils deviennent en tout cas à
des standards donc un écran toujours
plus grand elle cédait sur ce modèle là
des photos amélioré avec de
l'intelligence artificielle forcément la
reconnaissance de scène et ça on l'avait
déjà depuis l'année dernière des images
claires qui pourrait même selon ce qu'on
entend rivaliser avec la qualité d'un
réflexe ça je demande à voir en tout cas
c'est vraiment intéressant et ça va dans
le bon sens en plus de centaines de
paires faudra voir ce qu'on appelle le
link turbo alors c'est une techno qui
existent déjà qu'on portera notamment
sur le magic
tout cas sorti aux normes et qui est
réservée uniquement à la chine donc on
n'a pas ici en europe et qu'on n'a pas
d'ailleurs dans le reste du monde sauf
importateurs c'est donc une techno qui
vous permet lorsque vous allez
télécharger que vous êtes connecté en
wifi qui va venir vraiment choisir quel
sera le meilleur débit prendre la plus
faible latence entre la connexion wi fi
et la connexion 4g voire 5 g d'ici
quelques temps il va optimiser comme ça
il le plus rapidement possible saint
paraît plutôt bien attention néanmoins
si votre wifi n'est pas terrible et si
la 4g voire 5 g et meilleur à part
manger toutes les dates à de votre
forfait
ça peut aussi être faut faire un petit
peu attention à sa consommation
là-dessus seleccion qui complètement
optimisé sur l'intelligence artificielle
une fois de plus c'est au coeur
notamment du kerry 988 cocker
aujourd'hui les constructeurs de
vraiment avoir quelque chose de sûre
optimisé au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle que ce soit pour la photo
pour la performance pour le
téléchargement je vois aujourd'hui sur
l'ensemble de votre machine
aujourd'hui on a quelques bribes
d'informations sur ce smartphone on n'a
pas tout n'est pas encore dispo mais par
contre ce qu'on voit pas ce qui compte a
changé un petit peu lâche mais voilà à
léon ce recul on se met à l'aise on se
met bien on est détendu on est entre
nous voilà des paroles
donc est ce qu'on voit et ce qui est
super intéressant c'est que c'est déjà
d'une la faim en poche
typiquement l'encoche centaine partir en
2019 on pourrait dire bye bye aux
encoches à voir si apple nous sortir
encore une encoche en septembre 2019
allez savoir c'est pas impossible on
verra donc d'une la fin de l'encoche on
a vu aussi que sur le samsung galaxy s
10 c est 10 plus qui ne devrait pas y
avoir en poche mais néanmoins une caméra
intégrée à l'écran à voir comment ça va
être fusionnée pareil et pas très
longtemps solution que j'ai vu en tout
cas me paraît pas hyper intéressante on
verra réellement ce qu'il en sortira
donc d'une la fin de l'encoche de
toujours plus du multimédia avec des
très grands écrans donc ça c'est
toujours plus cool pour plus d'immersion
dont des smartphones qui vont devenir
toujours plus grand on se pose aussi la
question des smartphones à écran pliable
parce qu'on veut toujours des plus
grands écrans monde et cherche toujours
plus réduits qui tiennent bien dans les
poches ou alors dans les sacs
bon ça c'est aussi une question qu'on
verra mais un peu plus tard on voit que
du coup pour avoir ses plus grands
écrans certains se posent la question
d'avoir des slides à des tiroirs comme
sur le haut pour fine d'xcom sur le mail
x32 shiomi là c'est un autre choc effet
c'est une toute petite découpe de 4,5 mm
c'est plutôt intéressant aussi et on
voit également le troisième usages c'est
toujours plus de photos pourquoi pour
les partage sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qui ressort réellement de l'adn de ce
produit sont les usages sur lesquelles
on va continuer à aller en 2019 du
multimédia du gros gros gros multimédia
et du partage sur les réseaux sociaux ce
nachat instagram facebook youtube tout
ce que vous pouvez donc ça c'est cool
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez qu
est ce que vous pensez déjà de cette
idée d'abord cette petite des coupes en
façade sur le haut noir view vin est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
idée est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
une belle alternative à l'ems gauche est
ce qu'au contraire vous aimez pas trop
où est ce que vous préférez l'encoche
menditte moi tout ça est ce que préférer
les systèmes à tiroirs le système
coulissant
vous marquez tout ça est ce que vous
êtes d'accord sur le fait que les usages
des smartphones c'est vraiment du
multimédia et notamment de la photo je
vous invite à me marquer tout ça à
rester connectés puis a consulté ma
playlist pour connaître les différents
smartphones voire un petit peu les
différents tests il ya plein de produits
j'ai reçu le cros cole trekkeurs x4 tout
à l'heure donc on va en parler
d'ici quelques jours il ya plein de
tests à plein de smartphones deux côtés
on va tester le google pixels 3 pixels
3xl que j'ai depuis un moment où je
teste donc j'ai pas encore sorti la
vidéo on va parler du mail 20 on va
reprendre pas mal de choix donc je vous
invite à faire une seule chose assez là
restez connectés mark et moi tout ça en
commentaire était très bientôt on est
soit de vous ciao